all right so at this point you should
have to Center three by three blocks
completed I have the yellow Center for
my top completed and I have the white
Center for my bottom which means that we
have to do the remaining four centers
which are blue orange green and red
because there are more pieces in the 5x5
cube than the 4x4 there are also more
patterns that you will see when placing
the last two centers which are the
trickiest to place I will not be able to
cover every single pattern that will
occur when placing the last centers
however I'll give you some examples and
key methods that should prove useful
when trying to place them I will not be
using any algorithms for this step but
will instead logically explain how to do
the remaining centers with a little bit
of practice you will most likely come up
with your own way to solve any pattern
that you will see okay so what we want
to do now is to complete a third Center
to do so we're going to look around the
cube for a Center that is closer to
being completed than the rest we're also
going to hold the yellow and white
centers on the left and right sides of
the cube so that we don't mess those
centers up when placing the others since
I have already explained the basics of
making the 3x3 Center blocks I'm going
to go a little bit faster when placing
the next two centers so that we can go
over how to place the last two centers
in more detail all right so if I look
around the cube I'll notice that I have
two 2 by 1 orange blocks already solve
for us here and here so I want to go on
to place the orange Center next make
sure that you're holding the yellow and
the white sides on the left and right ok
so what I want to do is basically join
this piece up with that piece so I'm
going to put this one vertically and I'm
also going to put this one vertically so
that they're both in the bottom two
layers of the 3x3 blocks that they're on
now I could flip this piece up and I
don't have to worry about messing up any
of the other centers right now so I
formed a 2 by 2 now I want to get a 2 by
3 there by putting another one that is
already solved for us here so I'm going
to put this one vertically and I'm going
to get an empty spot vertically on the
bottom left now I can flip this piece up
so now I have a 2 by 3 and now I want to
get a 3 by 1 block next to that so here
is a corner center piece and here is an
edge center piece
this one's on the bottom so I have to
get this one on the bottom now when I
pair this piece up with that one I have
to be sure that I'm not messing this
piece up so once I get it like that I
have to turn it vertically so that I
could flip this back and I've reformed
that two by three so now I have a two by
one here and I want to form a 3 by 1 so
this corner center piece is down here on
the bottom left so I want to get an
empty spot on the bottom left up here
now don't forget when I flip this around
I have to turn it vertically so that I
resaw l've that 2x3 okay so now I have a
2 by 3 and a 3 by 1 so now I want to get
them next to each other so I'm going to
put this piece vertically on the left
side and I'm going to flip this piece up
because it's already vertically on the
right side so now I have solved the
orange Center so now we're going to go
on to solve the next easiest Center the
one that is probably the most solved for
us so here you'll see that I have a 2 by
2 green block already solved for us so
let's go ahead to place the green Center
next so here is a corner center piece
and here is an edge Center piece so I'm
going to flip this piece up and don't
forget that we have to flip it down to
resolve this orange Center so I flip it
up turn this vertically so I keep this
2x1 intact and then I have to flip this
piece back down to resolve the orange
Center alright so now I have a 2x1 green
block here so now I want to join it next
to this 2x2 so this is vertically on the
upper right so I'm going to get an empty
spot in the upper right here now I'm
going to flip this piece up turn this
2x3 vertically so that I can flip this
back down and I have to resolve that
iron Center so now I have a 2 by 3 green
block here so now I have to get a 3 by 1
next to that so here is a corner center
piece here's the edge center piece this
one's on the top so I'm going to put it
down on the bottom like the one that is
up here the edge center piece now when I
flip this piece up I'm going to
join it up with this one when I do that
I'm going to be kicking this piece out
so when I flip this piece up I'm going
to have to flip it back down to resolve
that Arne Center so I flip it up now
you'll notice that this green piece will
return to this upper left spot so if I
flip this piece up and flip these two
around 180 degrees when I bring it back
it will form automatically that three by
one block that I wanted all right so now
I have to get this three by one block I
have to get it next to the two by three
so now I'm not going to be able to just
put it like that and flip it around
because that's going to mess up the arm
Center so I have to get this vertically
on the right side so that when I flip it
around I kick out this piece so I'm
going to flip it around kick out that
piece turn it around 180 degrees and I
have to bring this piece all the way
back around to resolve the orange and
the green centers so now I have the
white the yellow the green and the
orange centers completed okay so if we
look at the last two centers which in my
case are blue and red you should notice
that some of the pieces have already
arranged themselves into groups or
blocks this is convenient for us however
you must realize that we will not be
able to solve the last two centers in
the exact same way as we did the other
four we only have these two centers left
to work with now and we can't form
pieces on the other sides since we
already have those centers complete what
we must do then is to get as many pieces
onto their proper side as we can and
then solve both centers at the same time
so I'm going to get as many red pieces
onto the red side and also as many blue
pieces onto the blue side and then go
from there at that point we should have
two similar patterns on each of these
sides alright so I see that we have a
two by one red block here and we also
have a two by one block here so let's go
ahead and join those going to put this
one vertically and this one's in the
upper right so I'm going to lift it up
get that new 2x2 out of the way
it stays intact and then I could bring
this back down so now I'll see that I
have another 2x1 block here so I want to
put that vertically this is in the
bottom left so I'm going to get an empty
spot in the bottom left here so once I
bring this up I'm going to see that I
formed a 2x3 block so I want to keep
that intact so I'm going to get it out
of the way and then I'm going to bring
this face back down so now what you see
is that we have a pretty common pattern
in which we have one edge center piece
that is incorrect basically these two
pieces have been switched what you want
to do in this case is you want to put
the the edge Center piece either here or
here so either on the left side or the
right side if we put this one on the top
face on the right side we have to put
this one on the front face also on the
right side then what we're going to do
is we're going to bring the one on the
front face and kick out the one on the
top face by twisting these two faces up
we're then going to turn the top down so
that this piece is facing down and then
we're going to bring the right back so
let me do that move one more time so I
have them both positioned on the right
in the middle layer I'm going to bring
this face up and then I'm going to shift
this down by twisting this towards me
and then put this piece back down then
what you'll notice we have a single
corner center piece here and now we have
these two pieces here so what I could do
is I could bring this piece up to meet
this piece so I'm going to put this
piece vertically down so now I could
join this piece up with that piece once
we do that we're going to have to
obviously put this back down so I'm
going to bring this up and now what I
want to do is I want to shift this
vertically and then I want to bring this
lone piece back down now I could join
this piece up with these two by turning
this horizontal now I could bring this
piece up
so now I have a three by one that I want
to turn vertically and bring back down
so now if you have a similar situation
to that you should have all of your
centers complete alright another
situation that you'll come across pretty
frequently is one way you have to corner
centerpieces out of place what you want
to do is basically get these as close as
possible to each other by putting one
here in the lower right and one up here
in the upper right you can also put them
here and here in the upper left and
lower left but you'd have to do the
opposite move and I prefer to work with
the right side what you do then is you
bring this piece on the front face up to
the top face by shifting both right
faces clockwise you're then going to
turn the top clockwise so that you see
this 2x1 block go horizontal what you'll
then notice is that when you bring this
face back down you're going to join this
corner piece with this 2x1 so I'm going
to bring this face back down you'll then
notice that we have a blue 3 by 1 block
here and a red 3 by 1 block here so let
me do that move real quick again once
they're as close as possible to each
other we're going to bring both right
faces up shift that clockwise so that
this is horizontal and then bring both
right faces down then in order to get
this 3 by 1 on to this face we want to
put this vertically and we're going to
also put this 2 by 3 vertically I'm
going to then bring this 3 by 1 up to
the top face turn the top 180 degrees
and then bring the right face back down
you should now have all of your centers
complete what we're going to do in the
next part is match up these triple edge
pieces